Jenna Dewan Tatum is getting her
Flashdance on with her new gig as brand
ambassador for Danskin I'm hoping I can
steal pieces from today's shoes I don't
think anyone's gonna wear them after
I've been sweating in this hot day long
my very first leotard was Danskin when I
was my first dance class I was 4 years
old and she's been dancing ever since
but it's her moves with husband Channing
Tatum and her adorable at home time with
the couple's 3 year old daughter Everly
that we love normal day for me is I get
up with my daughter
we generally watch Sesame Street we do
some breakfast we do dinner and we'd be
bedtime 20 million books 20 million
songs dance can want you to know you can
get all of Jenna's fab looks at Danskin
comm and the super busy mom is also
developing a new dance competition show
for NBC with Channing and a youtube
series based on their 2006 movie step up
but she still finds time to live a
healthy lifestyle I'll enjoy a green
smoothie in the morning when those
annoying people that actually wants a
greater than he's already